[Music]
matt is with us in rochester new york hi
matt welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave and christine thank you for
taking my call sure what's
up so my wife and i
we are i'm 31 she's 30. we're in baby
step 3b
thanks to your guys teachings that we
have been following for almost three
years now so
thank you thank you
um
so
we're getting to that point where we're
looking to become homeowners but it's a
little bit more complicated now that
home prices are quite a bit higher than
they were
you know year over year
and interest rates are going up too
so
one of the things
that i wanted to confirm is
when you guys say to budget 25 of
take-home pay
for a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
that does not include retirement and
college funding right but it does
include
property taxes insurance hoa fees etc
yeah i would just be your house payment
so the point is this
you can qualify for almost double that
payment
and when people do that you know what
happens they got no money they become
house poor
that's why they call them mortgage
brokers exactly you got the plan and
they become house poor because you're
broker and broker and so but you then
the next time a car comes up it becomes
a car payment because you've got no
margin to save up for the next car next
time the heat and air goes out you got
no margin
if it's over the emergency fund you're
screwed
because you you can't cover it and so
because it's all going to a stinking
house payment because you saddled
yourself with that so you're obviously
not going to go that far over into the
land of stupidity our guideline at 20
our guideline of 25 of your take-home
pay meaning uh whatever you're coming
home with not counting uh just a taxes
taxes out of your check is all
what would you get home after tax
now if you got uh if you got health care
coming out even health insurance i don't
you can take that out of the equation if
you want i don't care the point of the
whole formula is not the
nuanced exact percentage the point of
the formula is keep a small enough house
payment that there's margin in your life
and do it on a 15 year so you can get
the house paid off because that's what
millionaires do
absolutely so this past weekend we
actually got pre-approved for a mortgage
payment that was
29
of our take-home paid now this was
percent 30-year
conventional fixed rate
and
the problem was as well as with the
closing costs and the down payment that
was going to have to dig into our baby
step 3 fund so i know obviously that is
not something you guys would recommend
basically what i was working on was
so i built my own mortgage calculator
where
the property taxes so we live in new
york so we have pretty high property
taxes so on a 200k property you're
looking at about 6 300 a month or sorry
6300 a year
in property taxes
so
550 a month hazard insurance of about 75
dollars
prepaids
so and then for the closing costs
prepaids are not monthly they apply that
sets up your account to pay your taxes
and insurance
right right so
for our closing costs yeah so for for
our prepaids we were quoted 81.05
and our closing costs of 62.73
so just out of curiosity i created a
calculator where if say we were going to
go look at a 175 000 house it would
calculate those down to three
quarters of that hundred thousand dollar
quote just for rough math
so i looked into
okay like if we took out a fifteen year
fixed rate at
four point nine two percent which is
what the average fifteen year fixed rate
is running at so with our take-home pay
we could afford just for the mortgage
not counting the property taxes and
insurance about 957 dollars a month
but even out of
175 thousand 000 property
that calculates out to about
53 000 dollars 400 down
plus the prepaid i'm going to stop so
i'm what's your question
well so i guess the question is
is if we're going to be running for a
while longer
would it make sense to potentially start
doing
baby step four
so i have a roth 401k you can do
whatever you want baby step 3b
is zero going into retirement up to 15
going into retirement and baby step
forward and obviously the more you put
into retirement the less you're going to
put into your down payment fund
yeah yeah and so and the more you know
and what you're trying to do is get into
a house
at this stage
of the game and so here what do you guys
do for a living
so i'm a business analyst and my wife is
a teacher age so what did you make two
years ago
three years ago what were you making
before covid
uh before well actually i've had pretty
good
pay raises that's what i'm asking two
yeah so two years ago
i was at
60 000 and my wife what do you make now
she's
75 i do okay and so if you take out a 29
today in two years it's gonna be 25
percent
right okay and if that's pr
principal interest taxes and insurance
on a 15 year you know that's not the end
of the world my point is not to take out
you know 38 which you can qualify for
right right and you don't want to do
that and but don't over nerd this okay
it's a concept
the concept is big stinking house
payment means no money
so the concept is get reasonable house
payments so there's margin and i can get
through getting this thing paid off but
if you've got an income that's on an
upward trajectory like yours is you're
going to be at the 25 within 18 to 24
months and you're not going to have
wholesale violated this concept and made
yourself house poor that's what we're
trying to avoid not trying to figure out
some hard and fast parasitical rule the
the the reason we teach you this is to
limit your keep you from going out test
driving bentley's and then having to buy
a chevrolet it's just hard to do that
yeah that was my thought is it's not to
be legalistic it's not to try to follow
technicalities it's to give you freedom
in the long run and to build wealth we
don't want you tied into something
that's going to really stress you out
long term and prevent you from really
building wealth yeah but i mean you know
hey i couldn't do it it was a 25.5
percent
of my take-home pay oh shut up that's
not what we're talking about okay and
that's not this guy but i mean if you
get to the point understand the reason
for these things and then like make
grown-up decisions based on that guys
that's what we want you to do this is
the ramsey shop